si es muy bueno día es para ti el caso
sobre 2012 2016 se origina en base a una
investigación periodística publicada por
dos portales digitales de portar la
fuente y el portal emilio ja donde ellos
se publican correo electrónico recibido
por la ex asesora del ex presidente
rafael correa donde se desvela un correo
denominado receta a ver en este caso fue
conocido también como arroz verde o la
receta de arroz verde básicamente en
este correo adjunto se debe lavar una
detallada información sobre orígenes de
aporte financiero la trama se basa en
supuestos aportes financieros recibido
por parte de empresas transnacionales
aproximadamente 10 empresas
trasnacionales quienes liderados por la
presidencia de la república según la
fiscal general del estado se utilizaba
para recibir contratos de obra pública
esto fue una investigación que se
realizó por más casi 500 días de
investigación en lo que ha originado
en la ratificación de la sentencia de
ocho años al ex presidente es rafael
correa pero cuáles son las implicaciones
de este caso bueno básicamente luego la
ratificación de la sentencia y la
negación del recurso de casación al ex
presidente rafael correa y un total de
18 implicados esto nunca obstaculiza y
de igual forma hace perder los derechos
políticos del ex presidente rafael
correa y de su ex vicepresidente jorge
clarito básicamente no sólo durante los
próximos ocho años sino que básicamente
es la muerte política del ex presidente
rafael correa debe ser recordar que
luego de la reforma de la constitución
del año 2018 esto básicamente establecía
la muerte es civil de los ciudadanos
implicados en delitos de cohecho
peculado y concusión por lo cual la ex
presidente rafael correa no podrá
participar en las próximas elecciones
del año 2021
gustavo ortega muchísimas gracias por
este completísimo reporte desde la
capital ecuatoriana